[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for a
brand-new TIFF interview right now we
have the team behind a castle in the
ground with us a huge congratulations on
the movie not wasting any time here and
jumping right into it I'm curious what
inspired this the the loneliness
epidemic is something that kind of
fascinates and disturbs me to no end
where I can't stop thinking about it so
why jump into that subject matter I
think it's been a combination of just
research and exposure to certain
realities through my my father the work
he did when I was younger up until very
recently and just being alive on the
planet and and and not being able to
look away from what's undeniably
happening and it just grew slowly and
gradually it was never like a strategy
but then it became something that was
quite defined and then I got to
collaborate with some extraordinary
people that just made it you know vivid
and true and what is it like for the
three of you when a script like this
crosses your path because this isn't
exactly an easy headspace to kind of
live in for an extended period of time
so no no for lack of better terms at the
end of a shooting day do you kind of
need like a detox moment to sit down and
kind of relax and clear your head
it was really a matter of you have a
great responsibility as actors to
portray this experience accurately and
well and with respect and I think the
main concern and challenge and weight on
you was to do with that each day and
what we set out to do was certainly to
present the reality of this and how
normal it is and how current and
pervasive the opioid crisis is and but
at the end of each day I mean we got to
go and sleep in our beds and and I think
that the library beds any any job is
hard and this was definitely sort of
tough but at the end of the day with
really the focus was on making sure we
we did our jobs as best we could
yeah and I know you're a trained method
actor and filmmaker which again
fascinates me I'm curious just from the
acting perspective do you notice a
difference in his style of directing an
actor it's just awesome just really a
soulful way and to me the only way to
really direct a movie is the way Joey
goes about it because I feel like with a
movie that's very sensitive you need to
feel a certain confidence that if you
stray away from what's right or
something you're gonna have a director
who's still cheering you on and I don't
see that buzzing behind his eyes that
I've seen a lot of directors where they
have this anxiety like are you gonna do
it right like are you gonna do it and
they try not to do it but I can see it
behind their eyes and I felt that Joey
didn't have that anxiety instead he was
more anxiety that the car was going to
break down or then other stuff like that
but with us I felt like he totally
trusted we'd do something interesting
and and it could work and and I felt I
feel very indebted to him and I found a
lot of found a lot of comfort and
shelter and
like watching Family Guy when I got home
that was my thing I would I would go be
Henry all day and then I come home and
want to die and I'd watch Family Guy
what is the Family Guy for both of you
do you have a specific show or just
something you turn to in order to kind
of relax and recenter yourselves texting
Joey being like did I I thought today
that would be my one you being like no
really no you sure
probably just chain-smoking for me I
don't know honestly same during that
movie he got me to be a chain-smoker
fully know cuz I couldn't because they
only had the TV in the hotel so I would
just literally watch like whatever was
on the TV because I didn't bring my
laptop so it was kind of good in a wig
totally turnoff like usually I probably
would go home and watch I don't know
freaks and geeks if I want to feel good
or something but yeah I just forgot what
life is like when you turn things off
like that it was kind of nice
unfortunately the real truth is that a
lot of the time we probably probably all
of us went home and weird like
watch these opioid documentaries and
stuff and I'd watch these videos of
people nodding out and so honestly it
was kind of a non-stop thing when you're
doing as like a it wasn't running gun
because the movie is very perfectly I
think laid out but um when it says
balls-to-the-wall as this movie where
there's not that many days to do this
kind of a film I feel like you do have
to pack in as much research as possible
and so actually as much as I love to go
home and watch Family Guy like I was
going home and running a lot like like
at 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning I go down
to the gym and run because I you know
because I staying skinny and staying and
kind of keeping your mind relaxed so
actually running was a good way of
keeping the information for myself right
now what do you watch or listen to while
you run oh I was listening to Kendrick
Lamar damn a lot okay actually that got
me through a lot and I listened to Robin
Williams stand-up while I did it and
honestly that was the best yeah because
that relaxed me listening to Robin
Williams do stand-up made me happy and
relaxed me while I was writing I need
things for my running playlist so that
was a selfish question but thank you for
the end you smirk to me Emma Janis is
Robin Williams not good running comedy
not good running music I mean I have no
comment I love Robin Williams stand-up
what would you say to someone out there
that wants to make a more challenging
movie like this because every single
time I see something like this get off
the ground like I can't applaud it
enough because we don't see enough
material like this so for somebody else
out there who has a similar hope to make
a movie like this what would you tell
them well I appreciate that question I
guess like what Emma said really
resonates with me you know like we got
to sleep in our beds like I appreciate
what these folks were all willing to do
and to do grueling take after grueling
take and do it over and over again for
like tiny variations just to get
possibly to a closer core truth or
something is amazing but we're just
actors and filmmakers in the film
industry like you know we weren't
literally saving lives or curing
diseases and it's still a privilege to
work in this industry even when it's
really tough I think as an actor
filmmaker to see what they're willing to
do is really humbling and really special
but as the person who wrote it and
directed it like my life is good I mean
there's a lot of guilt to be honest with
being here like I sleep in my bed every
night like why should I be the one and I
think that it's a it's a beautiful life
however challenging it can be to be a
creative person and I think that
personally there's too much escapist
fare for my money and there should be
room for everything but it doesn't
necessarily have to be a glut of a
certain kind of candy that becomes bad
for you and then spat candy and then a
total dearth of things that maybe Sam
for something I'm nothing my flick does
but just in general my favorite films
and books and music have saved my life
and I just feel like you know if you
want to go out and do it I mean I'm I'm
I'm grateful to those people who are
going to do it because that's the stuff
that really is life's blood to me and
you know the the work that these folks
are willing to do and do do on
everybody's films is builds a I think a
global community of people with good
intentions who put love out and I really
believe in that filmmaker with that
mentality out there right now we do have
to wrap up but before I say goodbye one
thing we want to do right now I guess
kind of to celebrate life a little is
we're doing a Collider most memorable
moment so I have a list of things so
rapid-fire style first thing that comes
to your mind when I say this topic ready
first most memorable film premiere oh
good call the press of a premium we had
I [ __ ] up the game already the first
ever one we did memorable um solitary
men this premiering that a half premiere
was were both very special it's kind of
a funny story because the first time I
had a movie at TIFF and we got to be
back home in Toronto so that swag I ever
got I still wear that sweatshirt all the
time alright most memorable most
memorable meal Oh sushi and Japan yes
I don't know sorry I like the smoothies
I make it hold your onset vice what do
you reach for all the time on set oh man
no that's Mikey Solomon I was chewing
the licorice no I had to have those
smoothies because I can't anything I'm a
Bubble Boy so the smoothie guys I get ya
but my favorite meal and most memorable
meal was the first meal I ate after the
movie literally on the last day because
I like hadn't eaten in like two months
and then I like at the very last day ate
like three Subway sandwiches all this
stuff and then threw up in the hotel I'm
in left and I was like that's a way to
go that's the way to leave Sudbury you
eat way too much puke and get the hell
out of there I would I did the woof
program for a second we would eat all of
our food that was straight off the farm
that we were on and that was probably my
most memorable meals alright let's see
if we can squeeze two more in four
what's your most memorable fear overcome
jumping into rivers very neurotic all
the time about everything but I've been
encouraged to jump into rivers and I do
that now I'll do anything so you
encouraged me to jump in a river now
that doesn't sound good
I mean rivers have got like like creepy
like little you know sluggy things at
the bottom critters if you have any open
wounds you can get vials disease and so
I was I was nervous and leeches are in
lakes you're brave rivers I couldn't
sleep by myself I was like 13 I was
afraid of the dark it wasn't afraid of
the dark it's just like my brains would
go to like I'm the only person awake in
this house and then it's like oh I'm the
only person awake in the city and then I
think there's somebody coming into my
house and I got to protect my whole
family but I was like 7 so it took me a
while my older brother used to let me
sneak into his room and sleep on his
floor
that is so sweet any to you guys want to
add about okay waves we've over it let's
switch it up cuz okay I'll say I was
afraid to work with here ago crest and
then I conquered it cuz I did it what is
the most memorable rap gift you've ever
received
I got true or false by David Mamet when
I was seventeen and it was given to me
by Rose Byrne the legend actually when
you rap Amy bought me a bottle of wine
and it was just given in a very
heartfelt way so I still haven't opened
it because I'm a dork and I'm
sentimental and I'm like I'm not going
to drink it yet I didn't give Joy's [ __ ]
wasn't my point my most memorable was
slayer show no mercy on vinyl yeah
pretty dope
good calls all around I hate to wrap
this up but we have to so I'm gonna
thank you guys so much for being here
today and I'm gonna thank our wonderful
sponsor Nordstrom Canada for making all
these interviews happen that's it we're
out of here with this one like and share
this video before you leave and we'll
see you soon with more Tiff's coverage